okay so let me make an announcement on
this card
oh someone's asking for the zoom link uh
yeah i i don't know i couldn't pin it
but i think that they do have the resume
probably they just want to pin it
yes i wanted to pin it but i do you
wanna give introductions
sure i'd be delighted to um uh so we're
really excited to have anchor dragon um
come give our first um uh sort of
invited
um uh outside talk for our rl simon's
uh workshop um sort of semester kickoff
um anka's uh done a lot of really
amazing work in human robot
interaction um thinking about different
forms of trying to get the reward model
correct um and she's won
a slew of rewards including um the nsf
career a pk's
sloan a huge number of things have
acknowledged her really amazing research
accomplishments and her
graduates have already went on to join a
number of wonderful places including uh
dorissa siddig who's a
fellow faculty at stanford um so i'm
super excited to hear about her work
today
um on optimizing intended reward
functions thank you anka
thank you so much emma yeah the the joy
of being at berkeley is working with
these amazing students and actually
today
i'll talk about um kind of a
a a a piece through a lot of people's
work but i'd say that one of the
major uh influencers of this work is
dylan had been mental uh who is also
moving on to a faculty position
at mit super proud of dylan so i wanted
to
brag a little bit about about him as
well
um so i figured given that this is drl
bootcamp
it makes a lot of sense to talk about
a topic that's not only one of my
favorite topics that i've gotten really
obsessed by in the past four years
but also a topic that's basically kind
of challenging the very definition
of reinforcement learning as a problem
um that uh
you know this camp is all about and
replacing it maybe with a much
more difficult definition um that is
maybe also still work in progress
in terms of the definition itself but
definitely work in profits in terms of
how we might able to solve
that more complex problem so that's a
little bit of what the talk is about
uh now uh my background is in robotics
and i work on different kinds of robots
um i work on robot arms i work on
autonomous cars and um uh
quadrotors and indoor moba robots and
traditionally my work is um not so much
about
the reward functions during board
modeling traditionally my work was
uh was a lot and still is a lot on how
to
get these robots to achieve their
objectives when they're not alone in the
world right when they need to be
coordinating and collaborating with
people
um as part of what they're doing so um
so that's what i do but then it turns
out that the major bottleneck
in terms of being able to do that well
is defining what their objective
is in the first place so let me give you
um one of my favorite examples in in
this
so uh when i got to berkeley um i'm
still working with dorsal dorsal got me
into autonomous cars and the first thing
that i noticed
was that cars tend to be very
conservative
so this orange car here needs to is an
autonomous car
and it needs to get into the left line
and
um uh kind of that in order to take a
left turn or something like that
and so we can write down a reward
function that says
maximize efficiency avoid collision stay
on the road etc
and um if we do that the first thing
you'll notice is that the car
won't actually do very well uh because
essentially what it will do is it will
predict that the
human driver in the leftmost lane will
um
plan on keeping on going through in
their lane and so the autonomous car
will have to slow down and merge behind
them
in order to avoid collisions with them
that will be the optimal thing to do
and the reason that's not great is
because
if you have a lot of traffic coming into
that
that
left lane now you're screwed because
your options are you
either get stuck um and wait for a big
enough gap in traffic maybe that happens
in 30 seconds maybe in five minutes who
knows
or you keep going and then you miss your
lane and defend depending on how you
tune the
the the trade-offs and the reward
function one of these two things will
happen
those are basically the only two saying
options you have at your disposal
um because you won't go for something
that leads to collision and um
and if a human is presented
with these two options what they do is
they say screw it and invent a third
option
and that third option is to kind of
nudge yourself in there
despite your prediction of what this
other driver uh
in your left lane is going to try to do
you nut yourself in there because you
know that the other person will probably
slow down and it makes space for you
and so we worked hard on giving
the autonomous cars and maybe robots
more generally
this understanding that they get to
influence
what other humans do and we thought
about this as an underactuated dynamical
system
where essentially you're as a robot you
have actions that don't just influence
your state um they also influence
the actions that a human ends up taking
you don't have direct access to those
you can't control those degrees of
freedom
but you um influence them through your
actions
and so this kind of modeling of the
human robot interaction problem
um essentially fixed a lot of these
challenges of conservativeness that we
were seeing
but there's a flip side and the flip
side is that now if the car
can gain a tiny little bit of efficiency
um it has no problems cutting the other
person off and making them
decelerate five meter per second score
seven universe token square doesn't
matter as long as you can relied it on
them to the sellers so as long as it's
safe
no problem essentially being kind of a
jerk to
other drivers and so this exposed to us
something about the reward function
which is that oh wait we can't just
incentivize the car
to be uh safe and
efficient it needs to fundamentally
also care about the other people around
um in particular it needs to care about
their efficiency
as well so that you don't end up with
autonomous cars that are jerks to other
people
and so we revisited the reward function
we added a courtesy term
so far so good improved things in these
kind of highway scenarios
um but then at an intersection so this
is a four-way stop imagine the
autonomous car pulls off or at the same
time
as the uh human driven vehicle and then
what does the car do
that optimizes than your reward function
well it doesn't just wait for you it
doesn't go it doesn't wait for you to go
what it decides to do so the optimal
behavior here
seems to be to back off away from the
intersection
because that incentivizes the person in
the white vehicle to go through faster
through the intersection because now the
autonomous car is not a potential
obstacle that they need to avoid
and that's great for the courtesy term
um
it remarkably it actually works in user
studies people go faster to the
intersection so that's not really the
problem the problem with this being the
optimal behavior
is that if there's someone else in the
back
or if you have a passenger in your car
now that passenger
is really uh anxious thinking
why the heck is my car backing up right
um and so even with the addition of
courtesy
you don't you're not there your reward
still is missing important aspects
like passenger comfort or legibility to
other drivers and so on and so forth and
it feels like this endless list
and so we're getting good at taking task
specifications in the context of varel
reward functions
um and then use planning use
reinforcement learning depending on what
you know what you don't know about the
problem to turn that into optimal
behavior
um but what we often sleep
kind of under the rug is
that it's really hard to write down the
correct reward function it's really hard
to specify what you want
the uh rope these robots to do um
because
how do you capture you know comfort in
an autonomous car how do you write that
down and how do you trade off between
uh safety and not crossing the double
yellow line
and efficiency right what's kind of the
relative importance of these things how
do they combine
um so all of these are really hard
questions and these are examples from
autonomous driving i'll also share one
example
um that i really like this comes from
openai they did some work on
this game it's called coast runners or
coastal runners
and basically there's this boat in white
that is trying to race in a game
and it's not doing a great job
um so here's the actual course and you
see
our boat doing this weird loop while
everyone else is actually
racing and what's going on so this is
trying to deep reinforcement learning
um and it's not a bug with the deep
reinforcement learning that
this this policy is actually doing a
great job
because what it's doing is it's found
this loop
and it it timed it in such a way that it
just
gets these turbo boosters whenever they
show up and each turbo booster
gives it a bunch of points and the
reward function
that was specified here was points in
the game
and so the boat is like well you know
why bother
uh trying to race and trying to win
that's all really difficult
uh let me just do this loopity thing and
get
a lot of points that way and um
you know that's not what we intended
when we said
points in the game but that's what uh
this level uh in this particular level
of coastal runners that's what that
optimizing that leads to and so um
specifying rewards is hard you end up
with the behavior kind of taking you
by surprise sometimes negatively in new
situations and i think overall the
problem stems from
the fact that um the problem definition
is wrong
this is what i was trying to hint that
in the beginning so we pretend like the
ai problem definition is you have an
agent
there's a state space the agent can take
actions
that affect the state um there's some
reward function
that falls from the sky and then the
problem definition is
find a policy that optimizes that reward
function
cumulatively in expectation and uh
we define it this way because i mean it
makes sense
you have to make progress on something
and this is a concrete problem that you
can actually make progress on
but that's not what the real problem is
right so let's be clear about that the
real problem
is that um there's an agent
their state their actions but there's a
human
and the human wants something and what
the agent
is supposed to do is whatever the human
wants
the agent to do um and so i think that's
the problem that we should be going for
that it's not about optimizing a
specified reward it should be about
optimizing
intended reward where intended means
whatever a person actually wants you to
optimize
at some implicit level and so that's
what we should try to build these robots
to do
but that's hard because you know what
the heck is intended reward so um what
does it mean to optimize intended reward
let's make this a little bit more
concrete so what i did here
is i decided on a parametrization of the
reward function um so we're going to
choose some
space it could be a linear combination
of features so these datas would then be
weights on those important features
telling us how to trade off
it could be a deep neural network right
that
take the weights in a deep neural
network that takes uh state and action
as input and then outputs a scalar as
the output
um whatever it is right we choose this
space
we better hope it's expressive enough to
capture what we actually want
and then on the the idea here
is that this these parameters data their
hidden state um right so they're
sort of implicitly internal to the human
the robot doesn't get to just access
them
and so what the robot needs to do in an
ideal world and of course
then you know practical uh consideration
around compute come
come into play but an idea of what the
robot needs to do
is to maintain an estimate of these
parameters essentially to have a belief
a probability distribution
over what these reward parameters might
actually be
and try to estimate somehow right try to
have updates on this belief with
evidence
and so if you think about that problem
definition then um it sort of makes what
we currently do in reinforcement
learning
um look a little bit subpar because what
we currently do in reinforcement
learning
is the uh person the engineer the
designer
attempts to specify a reward function
like i was doing with the cars
um you know like open ai engineers were
doing with the boat
um and let's call this theta tilde and
this is uh
what's important to note is that this is
someone's best attempt
best current attempt maybe at a reward
function
their best guess at what should actually
incentivize good behavior
but note that this is not necessarily
one and the same as the two parameters
data um that would actually describe the
the reward function that
leads to the robot doing the correct
thing across time
uh in every new situation so we're gonna
call this data till day
and so what what we currently do in rl
is someone specifies the data tilde
and the robot basically updates its
belief automatically to
well that must be the definition of
the reward function so in other words my
belief automatically becomes
one if theta equals theta tilde zero
otherwise so that's just that's
you know that's ground truth that's
that's it it basically treats the
person's
specification as if they're some sort of
perfect oracle right as i said perfect
sensors that just
elucidates the reward um exactly
and we've seen an exam a number of
examples now where that's not actually
true where
theta tilde is not what we actually want
and you kind of keep on having to modify
uh as you encounter new and new
situations and on top of that after we
deployed the robot
that's it that's what you know that the
belief has been updated to this you know
one
on data until there's zero otherwise and
that's it um
that's what the robot optimizes for so
here's a robot that's programmed to
trade off efficiency
with maximizing uh these distances from
obstacles like
the table the floor and so on and for
collision avoidance purposes
and um just it's in my ola but imagine
that it's in my home and it's helping me
i kind of love the dishwasher um and i
see it moving and it's carrying this mug
that it has and it's in its end effector
and i get worried because it's keeping
that pretty high upright
and i worry that it if it drops it it
will break
and so what i might do as the end user
as the
user of this of this device is i might
see that behavior and intervene to fix
it so i might actually push the robot
closer
to the table closer to the ground to
correct its behavior
and now um
basically
that the fact that i did that
should tell the robot that something's
up the fact that i did that
should tell the robot look if
what i was optimizing for was the
correct thing to optimize
for the person wouldn't have needed to
intervene the fact that the person
intervened
means that something's up right but the
moment i set the reward to be set in
stone
and basically and a hundred one all the
probability mass
on one particular reward function we're
depriving the robot of that ability
right the the robot is just gonna take
this as some sort of disturbance
that's in the way um and it's just gonna
say
oh my god i'm so glad the disturbance is
over and i get
to go back to doing the task in the way
that um
i think is optimal um so that's a
problem
so i think that you know optimizing
specified word makes a lot of sense but
now from this lens of needing to
optimize
intended reward instead of the specified
reward
essentially what we're finding is that
robots tend to
learn too little from everything
that's that happens to them like people
saying stuff to them people correcting
them and so on and learn too much
over learn i'd say from the reward that
was specified
um so we're focusing on one source of
information but i think there's a lot of
other information
that we're leaving on the table like
this robot that i was pushing on
um was doing and so
it turns out that we leave more
information on the table than we might
think so people might physically
interact with the robot
um they might say stuff in natural
language
um they might um
they might sort of intervene and stop
the robot from whatever it's doing so
like if the robot is about to go over a
pot of water
and you switch it off in a panic to
protect it right well
this is uh something that you do because
of the you know what's about to happen
right now but i'd argue it's also very
useful information
about the reward because whatever the
robot was about to do uh
it was so bad that even just being
stopped is probably better
um and so from that you should have a
better idea
of of what you should do in general
because you have a better idea of what
the reward is
um so maybe my favorite so there's all
these examples of
what am i called um information that
that
robots are not really capitalizing on
right now my favorite one
is this one so imagine that someone asks
you to clean up a room
and you enter the room and you see this
beautiful
house of cards assembled uh in the room
now i bet that even though the person
didn't spell out oh but don't clean up
my house of cards
each and every one of us would basically
kind of read between the lines and leave
the house of cards there right no one
would destroy the house of cards
um and clean it up and so somehow the
very existence
of the house of cards is evidence
that the human cares about it and
doesn't want it destroyed
so i'd say that to what we do to what we
say
and even how we set up the environment
um
we leak information about what
we want and therefore we leak
information about what the robot should
optimize for
and i think this information can fill in
the blanks of what we forgot to specify
ahead of time
or or certain things that we
misspecified ahead of time
and so the question is how do we enable
robots to extract this information
um to capitalize it towards updating its
belief
um and being able to do better in the
future on
new tasks
so in other words how do we go
from observing the feedback that the
oldest information that the person is
is giving us and turning that into a
belief update
and and what's hard about this is that
we need to arm the robot with
a human model an observation model right
so this thing that tells us
um given the reward function that they
actually want
implicitly um what feedback what
what behavior from the human would we
expect what environments should look
like and
and so on and so forth so we need a
model that works for
all this diversity of human feedback
types
so now that we're kind of on the same
page about the problem set up here
of of wanting to create such an
observation model that can
take in all of these different sources
of information and
leverage them to update um to update the
robot's understanding about the belief
what i want to do for the rest of our
time together
is first talk about how we might do this
for the very special case of a specified
reward so if the person actually
specifies
a reward um what uh how we might build
an observation model for that
and then i wanna to generalize to all
these other different types
okay so when you specify a reward for
your robot
what does it mean for the reward you
specify to
not define the actual reward you want
but to be merely kind of evidence
observation about the reward you
actually want the robot to optimize
right how do we mathematically capture
this process that makes you as a
designer as an engineer
not actually end up with the right theta
parameters um why why would you not end
up with that how come there's this
disconnect between theta tilde what you
specify and what you
um and it's not that you know you take
your true data
and add some gaussian noise around it
like we can't just build an observation
model right now by slapping some
gaussian noise around theta
around data and say okay oh that's the
distribution data tilde is drawn from
there's there must be something going
wrong right for us to actually end up
with the wrong thing
so we thought about this for a while and
um
what we realized was that
at the core of what's going wrong is
that you as a human designer you can't
possibly look at
every possible environment and make sure
that the reward you specify ends up
working well
everywhere in every single possible
environment that the robot
encounters so what drives us of
optimality what drives this difference
between what you specify
and what you actually want is that you
only look at some development i'm going
to call it a development set
in kind of industry terms or do training
set of environments
and and you decide data tilde based on
that
and so usually what goes on when you get
surprised by this behavior
is some fundamental difference between
kind of what we might call the
development
test set and the the deployment set
right where you actually deploy the
robot
so we're not going to worry about bad
behavior during development because
um during the environment you're
actually tuning up the reward function
and uh you can still get a chance to
catch that and and fix it
we're gonna we're gonna worry about when
we see bad behaviors at
deployment time uh so when everything
works well during development and you
produce the data till day
and then at deployment time the robot
chooses the wrong behavior like in the
boat case for some reason the boat
encounters this level where it can win
with a lot of points
but it decides instead to kind of spin
in circles and get even more points down
right um and why does it do that because
the designer specified score
number of points is the reward function
and so
the idea here is that we don't just
write down a cost function and deploy
um the robot we tuned these costs are
these three words on a development site
so
score as a reward function must have
worked on the development side right so
the development side
must have been these levels in the boat
game where you could
win with many points or you could get
fewer points but then you would lose
so in other words score and winning were
correlated at development time
but that correlation was broken at
deployment time and that's kind of what
went wrong
um so the
the key idea here is what we're gonna
say is that the specified reward
okay it's not the same as the true
reward so we should not expect that the
behavior induces everywhere to be the
right behavior but
we do know for sure where it does induce
good behavior it induces good behavior
on the environments that the designer
used during development time
to tune it and test the reward function
and whatever the designer
actually landed on uh as the specified
reward the behavior it incentivizes on
those development environments
um or development scenarios that's good
behavior meaning it has high true reward
so that's what we're going to assume
that's we're going to say this the
disconnect between specified and true
reward
really comes from this difference
between development and deployment time
and what we what we're going to based on
observation model on
is that the specified reward only works
well on we only know it to work well on
the development set
and not everywhere um maybe another way
to say this is that
what we specify is comes in a context
and it's important for the robots to not
interpret it literally but to interpret
it as part of that context and the
context here is this development set
that we're working with
that's our context that we're drawing on
to to define the reward function
so mathematically the probability of me
writing down
uh theta tilde um
uh does not um just depend on what
theta star the thing that i want is it
also depends on the development
environments
and so um it depends basically if you
look at what behavior theta tilde
incentivizes in the development
environments
then the lower the the cost or the
higher the reward
of that behavior is with respect to data
star
the more likely i am to write down that
theta tilde as the reward function
um so kind of to get more intuition of
this basically here's what this
observation model does
what it does is it says here's here's a
plot where
on the x-axis we have all trajectories
and the one the y-axis we have the
the reward the negative reward lower is
better the negative reward
on the development set and this is going
to be respect to different
data so there's data star that's what i
actually say one but of course i don't
know that it's only implicit in my head
um here's another set of data parameters
i'm not going to specify that because if
i optimize that
that leads to a trajectory that does
pretty poorly with respect to data star
i'm going to catch that that's not going
to be what i end up specifying to the
robot
but there's all these other reward
functions
that end up producing trajectories on m
devel
that theta star likes that it that have
good reward respect to r theta star
and then the problem comes when that
breaks at deployment time the problem
comes when
in the deployment environments all those
different reward functions
no longer agree on what's good and
what's bad
um in particular they no longer agree
with data star
um and so what this this model tells us
is that it kind of cautions the robot
that
if m devel was the environment that
these were based on or the set of
environments
um the it cautions the robot that any of
those green
green possible uh cost functions reward
functions
are possible are things that the that
the designer
might specify if they actually want data
start because there's not a good way for
them to disambiguate between them so
kind of back to the boat real quick
urban
behavior is an m devel um and uh
kind of just for the person
understanding this let's say that the
robot kind of magically has access to
these many different features that might
matter like winning like score
whatever it is um and so we
um we told the robot to maximize score
we chose data two
and now instead of just optimizing tera2
everywhere what the robot does is it
says okay let me look at what behavior
disincentivizes what policies come out
of this
in the development set well in the
development set i end up
getting a lot of points if i do this i
also by the way end up winning
um now let me look at what which of
these reward functions in my hypothesis
space are like that that behavior
well of course maximizing score likes
that behavior kind of duh that's what i
optimized to obtain it um minimizing
winning minimizing score
do not like that behavior and so that's
how the robot knows that
the person says maximize score and it
trusts that the person didn't mean
don't win or don't optimize score
minimize score right um but what the
robot doesn't trust is that the person
could have really disambiguated between
winning and score because they both like
the same behavior in there
and so now the robot has this
uncertainty it's not that the robot so i
want to pause here and emphasize
something
it's not that if you take theta tilde as
evidence about data star
all of a sudden the robot knows that the
person wants the robot to win and not to
optimize score that's not what's
happening at all but what's happening
that i think is really important
is that the robot gets this uncertainty
where
it trusts some things that the person
said but it
but it knows that it doesn't know
whether the person actually wants score
like they literally said or maybe they
actually want winning
um and this uncertainty is really
valuable so we we do this belief update
we get this uncertainty
and now what we can do is we can plan an
expectation which is kind of hedging our
bets a little bit
between the different options we can
also do risk-averse planning so kind of
protect against
the the kind of the worst case um some
notion of worst case reward function
that's still
high likelihood um we try this by the
way in motion planning for arms you do a
lot of motion planning kind of around
people
and um what's hard with even this
problem
is that there are these different
aspects of the task that are
important so these aspects are like
avoid collisions
stay far enough away from fragile
objects like the vase but also
have a comfortable distance away from
the person and you know by the way
the person stores so different from the
person's head and so on right how do you
prioritize all these different things
how do you mesh them together
and as designers we kind of maybe
implicitly know what
we would want the behavior to look like
but we have a hard time sort of spelling
out the weights in a cost function that
correspond to that
and so what we do is we tune it on
certain environments
and you know we look at the resulting
trajectories and everything is great
and then here's a new environment where
we tried a reward function that worked
well
on a lot of test development
environments
and here it just decides that the
optimal thing to do is like to plow
through the vase
well i had no idea why i mean could we
fix this with hard constraints but
that's not the point the point is that
there's
always things that come at attention and
you always tune them for
and they work across several things and
then they break um
and i don't know that this is different
from the
training environments or anything like
that i couldn't tell you there's no like
features that are no longer correlated
there's something going on but i don't
know what's going on
um qualitatively um and so
what the robot does here is
takes that reward that i specified on
those
training environments as evidence does
this whole update that we were talking
about
obtains a posterior now has this
uncertainty and then
plans an expectation over that and it
ends up not actually colliding with
stuff and doing a kind of a better
job keeping maintaining these trade-offs
that we'd like
um so this technique leads to better
behavior with
less time being put in into designing
the
the cost function it's what we found
we also did some some this is these are
results from some user studies with
people actually trying to define these
cost functions
um now what's kind of not so great about
this
so of course a big limitation of
everything that i've taught so far is
that
uh we get convenient access to the right
features right like with the boat in the
toy example that i gave
winning we magically knew that that's a
thing or
uh with the motion planning um we know
that these distances are important right
we just don't know how to kind of weight
them prioritize them but we know that
they're important
and so we had some experimentation
um but that's still ongoing and it turns
out
it's pretty hard to do but we had some
experimentation with um
uh what if you don't get access to these
features and we looked at this
very simple this was our kind of our
initial experimentation was in this
little toy environment um
called uh lava land where basically you
have these different types of cells
um and you don't get to know what the
type of cell is you get some sort of
noisy measurements
that relate to the type of cells you get
these we call these raw observations
just stimulate like what would happen if
you had cameras looking at the world but
it's a much more simplified example
and then the development said so the
terrain is like grass dirt target and
then there's lava but the training
the development environments have no
lava and so you end up
as as a programmer you end up designing
a reward function by kind of training
these classifiers to detect grass to
detect dirt
and then you put in trade-offs between
these things and that's how you specify
the reward
and so you don't build a classifier for
lava because there's no lava and you
don't think that i'm going to ship the
robot to hawaii so that it needs to
encounter lava
and now when you actually do um
inference using that specified reward
turn that into a posterior and we do
mcmc sampling for that
um in in because the space is pretty
high dimensional um when you turn that
into posterior and then you do risk of
responding with respect to that
it's kind of amazingly enough that leads
to the robot avoiding lava at test time
and so kind of implicitly even though
the robot doesn't have a notion of lava
implicitly in the space of reward
functions that it's maintaining a belief
over
there are going to be reward functions
that like lava and don't like lava at
some implicit level
and uh and uh the robot realizes that it
has uncertainty over that and then that
turns into
um the risk avoiding behavior being to
avoid the lava
so i thought that that was really
promising what really bugged me about
this though is that if lava were a
pot of gold then the robot would also
avoid the pot of gold right because
that's also new and that's also not
something that i've talked about
and so where we've been moving with this
line of work has been
um to to essentially
um well i should say that okay so here's
he's kind of a real example where the
pot of gold thing happened so um
autonomous driving right we take in
these um
uh development environments we specified
reward functions robot does the
posterior update
and guess what everything sucks now
because there's so much uncertainty
about what might
what might be good what might be bad
that you just can't make progress you
get
you end up being really really
conservative and so
that's a problem and so what we've been
trying to do now
is leverage that posterior
to go back to the person and seek an
environment kind of design an
environment for them
um which means kind of initial
configuration of all these different
uh things that could be in a scene um
that that's kind of an as much as
possible an edge case and which
sort of the what they kind of specified
so far breaks and our version of that
was find an environment that maximizes
expected info gain
and what that turns into is proposing to
the person
environments where essentially the
current reward function
has high regret with respect to the true
reward function so basically because
they're environments in which the
rewards sort of tend to contradict with
each other
what happens is a lot of these
environments and that being things where
the behavior that you would normally see
would not be the right one
um so that's pretty cool and then that
leads to actually being able to
um i'll skip this but actually perform
better
um over time with more fewer
environments
so that i think the active part is
really important it's this notion of
exposing the person to edge cases so
that you could actually
make progress on what you don't know um
so step one was know what you don't know
step two is actually make progress on
resolving what you don't know
and um i think though the
the thing that that's kind of
bottlenecking all of this is how you
decide to parametrize the reward
function so at the very beginning of the
talk
when i said our real problem is optimize
intended reward
the next thing i said was okay here's
how we're going to actually make
progress on this we're going to choose
a way to parameterize the reward
function and we're going to say the
parameters of this are unknown
and that that choice i'm not sure how to
really resolve
because i have two options i mean i have
a spectrum of options with two extremes
i could design the features and then
i don't have a lot of expressiveness
there so i could do things that resolve
like the motion planning example that we
were talking about but
it's really hard to do things that will
then sort of come up with oh
lava might be a thing like there's just
no way to express that in that space
um i could use deep neural networks and
um
then uh they can express all of this
but then i have to have uncertainty over
neural networks
and i have to work with the person and
keep querying them
until i resolve that ambiguity and
because everything in their mother could
be a reward function
now that's very limiting right in terms
of the number of queries that i'm going
to make
but this is a pretty fundamental
trade-off and i have no idea how to
solve this
okay so um
this was all under uh how much amount of
time okay
this was all under what if the person
specifies something but i promise that
we'll also try to generalize this right
so this is one bit of evidence that you
get
it's not the definition of the reward
it's evidence and this is how we can
actually leverage it
to understand more about what the person
actually wants
um so
what about all these other types and
let me share a little bit about two
other types that we know
a lot how to do one of them is
comparisons
so if the person if you show the person
two trajectories and the and ask them
which one is better
um and if they say psi a the projector
on the left is better than side b do
that
we know how to turn that into evidence
about the
uh underlying reward function and in
particular
the way we do that is through this
notion that the person
we think of the person as making a
rational choice with respect to the
reward so we think of the person as
having these two choices
a and b and they based a choice on the
cumulative reward of one trajectory
versus the other
um and generally we tend to say allow
for a little bit of noise the person
isn't perfect
at making this choice the person uh
picks maybe in proportion to the
exponent of the reward
so that's one thing now this this isn't
this is this observation model we've
been seeking we know this it's been
very well studied a second example where
we know how to interpret
human feedback really well is
demonstrations and so that's inverse
reinforcement learning in particular
this would correspond to bayesian
inverse reinforcement learning where
we'd say
you know what the person has choices um
now they're just all of the possible
trajectories that they could have
demonstrated in this scene they picked
one of them
right um so now they made an implicit
choice as opposed to an explicit choice
but it's still a choice and it's still a
choice
with respect to the reward function the
cumulative reward of the
of the trajectory so that's inverse
reinforcement learning um
and again you can make that noisy and i
want you to notice that it's the same
thing that comes up where you have
the probability of a trajectory being
proportional to the
exponent of the reward the thing that's
different now is that the person didn't
make a choice between two things
so that that normalizer is not over two
trajectories over all possible
trajectories that the person could have
demonstrated
but didn't so those are two well studied
aspects
when we have our specified rewards
that's also a choice so the choices here
are all the possible reward functions
that the person could have specified
implicitly they made a choice they chose
one of them they chose data till day
and they the the problem is
what would it mean for them to choose
based on the reward
right what is the reward of a not a
trajectory
but a specified reward function sort of
it's the you get a syntax mismatch here
um and so our answer was that
they they choose the the
specified reward based on the reward of
the behaviors that that specified reward
induces
in the development sense right so it's
again a choice that they're making it's
again respect to the reward function but
we just grounded
the specified reward this proxy into
behavior so that we can evaluate the
reward function
um so they compared that with any other
possible reward function that they could
have specified and implicitly made a
choice
based on that and that was that model
um good so
when um so so in general right
what we can think of is that the person
has some choices
they're not necessarily behaviors but
they're choosing
implicitly or explicitly among those
choices
based on uh a kind of a grounding
of those choices into behaviors and
evaluating the reward of that grounded
choice um so they're choosing sort of if
choices are c
if they're choosing c star they're
comparing the behaviors corresponding to
c
star the reward of those versus the
reward of
behaviors corresponding to their other
choices and then they're picking in
proportion to that and so far
this is fit with comparisons it's fit
with demonstrations and it's fit with
the specified reward
and it turns out that when you ask how
you should extract this leak information
from other things um the crazy thought
for us
is well maybe we can just interpret
anything as a reward rational choice
that the person is making sometimes
implicitly
and it turns out that you can you just
have to figure out
what were the choices right because
sometimes they're implicit
um like what what they what they could
have said but didn't what they could
have shown but didn't
and then how these all translate to
behavior um
so with corrections for instance what i
was showing in the beginning that i push
on the robot
well that's an external torque that i'm
applying and you can think of it as a
choice that i'm making it's a choice
between
different external toys that i might be
able to apply um and it's also based on
the reward
of the grounding of that external torque
into a trajectory which is something
that we call deformed trajectories
and that leads to um i push on the robot
it interprets that as a choice it takes
it in as evidence about the reward and
lo and behold the robot actually stays
closer to the ground
who would have thought good robot
less frustrating um when when the robot
when i teach when i turned the robot off
that's also a choice because i could
have left i could have done nothing i
could have let it run and i didn't
and so these two choices
you know turn the robot off not turn the
robot off map
also to behavior right they mopped the
robot being stopped there for us the
time horizon for sort of like continuing
along what it was planning to do
um and sort of the person is telling us
that one thing is better than the other
they're making a choice
and then finally the the my favorite one
is you know what's up with this house of
cards um how is that
how does that relate to truth how do we
get information from that
um and so here's our version of this so
so far we've talked about
these sources of information that look
at human behavior of some shape or form
so
if i'm in a room and uh the person
didn't tell me to not break
this vase that's in this room uh i would
have had to see
the person actually
actively avoid the vase for me to figure
out that the vase is important right so
that's kind of what inferring from
behavior looks like
um but if i just walk into this room and
i see the vase
there and i know that the universe
didn't just start this way
right people have been in this
environment i should be able to actually
figure out that the vase is important
from just the existence of that base in
the environment so
if i deploy the agent in an environment
where the human has been acting because
the human has been acting according to
their preferences
that that state of the environment
itself leaks information about what
people want
um so that's kind of the house of cards
part and so
the way we've gone about interpreting
this is you know lo and behold we think
of it as a choice now
what are the possible choices well
they're states of the world right
because you get one state and not
any other state that could have been the
current state of the world but wasn't
um how do you choose
based on reward how does the person
choose a state
well i the trick here was that
a state of the world does correspond to
trajectories
and does grounded trajectories that you
can evaluate reward on
it corresponds to trajectories that have
happen
and they end at that particular state
and what the person is doing when
they're making the choice of a state of
the world
is essentially you can think of it as
comparing between
the trajectories that ended at that
state that you actually see
versus trajectories that did not end at
that stage versus all
basically for all other states that then
map the trajectories that end there
um and so the way this works is uh the
robot sort of simulates the past in its
head and says well if the person wanted
to break the face they would have just
gone through and broken the vase
if they didn't care about the vase they
would have also gone through and broken
the vase because that's efficient
um so if they didn't want to break the
face they wanted not to break the face
then they would have avoided it and
that's the only one that actually
corresponds to the
the current situation that i'm seeing
and so that's how we get that
kind of information okay um so yeah
there are some questions
in uh yeah
um do you wanna take a look at them
or anka if you're about to be done then
we could pop whichever you prefer we can
yeah let me do i think i'm maybe one
minute away
okay oh so i'm gonna do that and then
we'll talk cool okay
so just a couple of things on this
information that you can get from the
state of the world so
um a couple cute examples indulge me so
when you are
in this room with a face you and the
person says go to the door and you're
like oh
okay well the vase is still there so
probably the person wants me to avoid it
and the robot goes and avoids it
um really cute example actually is with
not just
avoiding unintended side effects but
actually creating desirable side effects
so
um room with a train the train is still
running the train would run out of
batteries and die
but the train is still running so
instead of just going to the door the
robot acutely goes
takes the battery repairs the train and
then goes
because it figures out that something
that the person probably cares about so
anyway i thought that was really cute
um in general yeah i think that that we
shouldn't take these rewards for granted
i think we should really think about the
real problem
now that we have all this progress in rl
it's getting a good time to start
thinking about the real problem of
trying to optimize what people actually
want and that means that you have to
make sense of
all of these different types of
information that they're giving you
um sometimes without even realizing that
they're giving you this information
um and and i think that thinking of them
as making choices
that make sense with respect to the
reward in one shape or another
has been a way to get towards that um
that goal of making sense of this
information of course the thing that
that
i worry a lot about these days is uh
that they're not that rational with
respect to the
to the reward function and i have a lot
to say on that maybe we'll come up with
in q a
um but yeah i think you know task
specifications
it be them rewards or constraints or
whatever they are they're so easy to get
wrong and we shouldn't really rely on
them
we should really involve the robot into
this problem of
of look let's work together
to figure out what it is that you want
me to do so that i can do that well um
and the generalization of this is
something that we call assistance games
where we really think of the human and
the robot
working in the same space together at
the same time
when the human is trying to to teach the
robot what they want and the robot is
trying
to take actions that that gather
information about that
so with that thank you very much and uh
these are the the great students that
did
uh this work as well as faculty
collaborators here on this work uh peter
and beyond stewart russell
so thank you and we can go to q a i'll
just stop sharing
thanks emma that was super interesting i
don't know can you i don't know if you
see them anka so um in case it's helpful
i'd be happy to
curate um so one of um the first
questions that we got was sort of
asking i and this is related to a later
follow-up question too was sort of
there's also the possibility of um
dynamics changing over time or reward
non-stationarity um and so
my impression of your talk is that
you're mostly thinking about a case
where the reward function is
latent but static as opposed to
dynamically changing
but that's right so the work that i've
presented so far we think of these
parameters as being fixed they're static
we just don't know them and so our
estimate of them changes
but um there's this there's this one
piece of work that we've done
um that may be that maybe get well so
first of all i think that
actually changing the rewards are almost
like a red herring and let me explain
how
so um when you look at people
if you have the wrong feature space uh
in the wrong model of them it might
definitely seem like their reward is
changing like their preferences are
actually changing over time
um but but there's this one bit of work
uh we called it as the um assistive
bandits this is the multi-armed bandits
and and the thought there was that
maybe people are actually themselves
still discovering
what their preferences are um so you
know if you go
on netflix and you pick a movie it's not
that that's the
optimal thing according to your
preferences that you're figuring out
what genres you like what genres you
don't like and so on you're gathering
this information and updating
um and so in this little bit of work we
were we were modeling people
as actually learning about their
underlying rewards so the person's
estimate of their own reward was
changing
um so that means that you know what they
were acting according to was changing
but the actual
underlying reward function their actual
underlying preference wasn't um
so it's very interesting to think about
you know when is the reward actually
changing versus when we just
have either the wrong model the wrong
representation such that according to
what we have access to it seems like
it's changing
but but it's not in any case if people
are actually learning about what they
want turns out
really important to account for that
otherwise your reward inference gets
gets really screwed
um great and another question was um and
i'm not so familiar with this one but
you might be
is um how does this approach compare to
semantic navigation approaches
that's not an area that i'm personally
familiar with but maybe that's something
you're familiar with
magic navigation maybe ignacio who asked
this is can people unmute themselves and
clarify
is that so chubby you can chime in if
i'm wrong about that
um or if you want to update well i don't
know
the baby is like my best guess at
but you know this the the
in basically in any form of navigation
i think the differentiation is um
you you even if you know about the
semantics of the world
you still have to have something that
defines you this is good this is
bad and so even if you have ways to
sort of get at these high level features
right like you actually can't say
oh that's lava um you still have to
attach something
that says well that's good or that's bad
and what we're worried about is these
situations where
there's so many things to think about
ahead of time that you won't have
you want to attach values to to these
different
these different sort of types of of
objects or worlds that you could
encounter
and so um so we're we're we're kind of
worried that okay you'll forget
something um or even worse
um maybe maybe if you know if you have
access to lava and the person forgot to
say that it's bad it's very trivial to
know okay
i don't know i have uncertainty over
that but if you have access to these
things and the person said one thing
but because you know features were
actually correlated and so you know they
put the weight on this
but that's not doesn't mean the more
like the the call the
the the effect not the cause and the
underlying thing that you really want to
penalize is something
else that's the type of reward design
mistake people make all the time
it's so easy to look at the sort of the
behavioral aspects and say well that's
bad that's good
and not look at the underlying causes
but when you don't do that
you're you're basically looking at
things that correlate with the reward
that you want on the environments that
you're looking at
and then that correlation breaks later
and then you get in trouble so
so i think i don't know if that really
answered the question but that's how i
would think about that like semantics
are useful in giving you
a lot of information and maybe
structuring the reward space that you're
doing and friends in but i still worry
about people not being able to specify
the reward properly within that space
thanks could you clarify a little bit or
somebody wanted to you to omit one to
you to re-explain what you meant by
implicit choice by the human
yeah so um good question so
when the person has the person to
compare two trajectories a or b
they're making an explicit choice right
they're saying a is better than b
when they're excuse me when they're
demonstrating
a behavior or when they're choosing a
reward function or when they're using
natural language to say that was bad or
do this or or and what not
that choice is implicit it's implicit in
the sense that the set of choices wasn't
presented to them explicitly
so that them and the robot know both
that's what we're looking at and then
they picked one
out of it um it was implicit in that
they demonstrated this behavior but
implicitly they're saying that that
behavior is better than all of the other
things that they could have demonstrated
but they didn't
um and it's important to realize the
implicitness because essentially
what this can lead to is this form of
misspecification where
you're interpreting the choice set that
they had the options that they have as
being one thing
but they weren't thinking about that
they were thinking about something else
so oh i didn't realize i could you know
turn the robot off
and so now you're like well you didn't
turn the robot off that has meaning
but it doesn't because that's not what
they were thinking about as an option
and so
so realizing the implicitness of it
means that you can start
looking at potential problems that arise
from misspecification this mismatch
between what the person consider as
alternatives
um versus what the alternatives actually
were
and i guess to build that one of the
things that it makes me think about is
there's certainly nice connections also
to the imitation learning and inverse
reinforcement
learning community and there i think
there's often been an implicit
assumption that the demonstrations are
from an optimal
agent and so do you think part of the
part of the many contributions you guys
are making is say we're thinking about
more rich models of demonstrations
and given an online reward function
instead of just an optimal agent
that is making these demonstrations yeah
so this is the bit of work that i had
no time to go into but that's a really
good question am i so
um maybe i'll i'll do one minute on this
because it's so important so yeah
whenever i kind of talk about this
something that people understandably ask
and get concerned about
is that their people don't make rational
implicit or explicit choices they're
just not rational and
the way the field has kind of papered
over this in the case of comparisons and
demonstrations
is with this kind of adding noise right
saying well the probability of the
choice abortion to the exponent of
the the reward of that choice and that
goes back all the way to
some economics models um
lucy's axiom of choice is like the root
of that and then sort of it evolved from
then on
the problem is that that that just
plasters over kind of papers over with
noise some systematic biases that people
have
and the trouble is that we have decades
of behavioral economics research
that is really pointing to how their
these biases they're
all sorts of them right um and so
there's a lot of work that's describing
these biases someone qualitatively or
saying okay here's what
describing what happened in particular
situations there's a few like prospect
theory for instance that have made it
into
sort of ways to model that
mathematically
now one thing that we've we've been
making some headway on
is this notion that maybe people
appear to be really biased and
suboptimal
but maybe they're actually they are
rational but under a different kind of
model of the world
under different assumptions about how
the world works um and that might be
what explains not that they're they are
suboptimal let's get it clear
but they're suboptimal in a way that
that makes sense
given the compute constraints that they
have that's notion of bounded
rationality but also given sort of the
assumptions that they're making about
the world and so for instance
people operating a robot have no idea
about the dynamics of that system so
they have a hard time predicting the
consequences of the action on the robot
but um their actions which are really
suboptimal and noise they make a lot of
sense under this very
simplified physics intuitive physics
model that they kind of have that
they're operating on there
if you realize that then all of a sudden
human actions might make
a lot more sense right so there's kind
of these transformations upon the
beliefs that they have about the world
maybe their observation model the way
that they're processing information
their dynamics model that they're using
to make decisions um
their um uh you know perceptive
prospector is basically the perception
of the
of the um reward right that the reward
sort of gets kind of capped and
in both ways um and if you
we've been trying to estimate those
alongside with the reward
it it's it's it's challenging because
there's a lot of ambiguity right you can
flip the dynamics model around and get
this totally different thing
um but uh but at least you know when you
couple that with the uncertainty message
you end up sort of understanding
different options and then you can start
probing at the space i think that's
super interesting important and i've
seen tom griffiths who i think you guys
have collaborated too on some of this
work
and seeing how yes if we think about
sort of the bounded computation that
people might have a lot of these things
might be rational
i want to pull a question from the chat
message right
i'm not sure if you see it or not but
it's from akshay um and he was wondering
about
if if the rl algorithm is using the
uncertainty and actually just correct me
if i've got this wrong um its behavior
might change
but then the human might also be
thinking about how all the rl if i know
that the rl
algorithm is going to do bayesian
updating um could this
change how the human is trying to
provide information like if i try to
correct the robot midway
i might over correct it so it'd be like
no really this is what my cost function
is and so i'm using
my model of how the robot works yeah
well that is a fantastic question
in fact in a sense my phd thesis was
dedicated to
to this question because it was
basically on how
you can actually act differently to
convey information
about your goal about your intent um
but uh yeah so so at the very end of the
talk i'd reference something that we
call assistance games
um and and that's kind of our overall
formalism for the problem of i'm working
together
the robot and i are in a team and we
we get rewarded by the same overall
reward which is the reward that i
that i care about but um the robot
doesn't know the parameters of that
reward and so that solving
computing equilibria um of it's it's
you know we call it a game but it's
really a deck bomb dp um
because the reward is this shared um so
there's no there's no it's not general
islam it's not zero sum there's common
payoff
but but um but the strategies that come
out of that look like the person
actually trying to be informative
and the robot crucially kind of
understanding that the person is gonna
try to be informative
and so you end up with this but we can
only do it for toy tasks is the problem
but you end up with these really
beautiful behaviors where
the the robot so the person
um basically there would be for one
option
there would be for one intent um there
would be
a very clear way to signal that and then
for another intent there's not a clear
way to signal that basically anything
you could do you would be able to do for
the you should do for the other intent
as well
um and so the person but but the person
either waits or even does one of these
other things and then the robot knows
that the person would have been
informative if they could have been
so that's not it and so you know you
kind of get this like turtles all the
way
um it's super interesting but there's
there's a cautionary tale too which is
some work that smith did
where we were looking this isn't in um
and uii is looking at the specification
of this model so
in light of this work of let's assume
that people are actually trying to be
informative and leverage that
kind of came smitha's paper which showed
that um
if you assume people are informative and
you get that wrong
that's really bad um whereas if you
assume that people are not trying to be
informative they're just
you know optimal kind of in isolation
just doing their thing their rational
choice thing
uh and then and and and and then that's
what you're using
the fact that the person is best
responding to that is is helpful to you
anyway so you can leverage that um so
the mismatch is much the
the the robustness of the specification
is much higher when you're just assuming
a naive person
than if you're using um uh you're trying
to assume that a person is informative
and even when in experiments people are
trying to be informative
even when we fit the model to that um
the model is still not perfect and and i
kid you not
the inference was worse assuming that
you know fit model which was more
accurate to what they were actually
doing
than assuming the naive person so it's a
native person is really robust so anyway
really beautiful question actually thank
you so much for that um
it's really nuanced and complicated but
yeah uh
we've looked into some of that i guess
and actually said thanks so much for the
answer
um uh and chava i think we have to leave
in a minute so i'll let you be the um
final time here but i had a really quick
question which is i was curious how you
think about the
the trade-off between like the cost of
elicitation essentially because um you
only had time to really briefly talk
about some really interesting work on
using these priors to then either design
environments or ask people which i think
is a super interesting direction
um but the question of how do you how
frequently can you sort of elicit
information from people about their
preferences and their reward function
and when to do it you know do you do the
beginning do you do it at the end you do
it in the middle
it's certainly a question we're thinking
about for some of our own work and so i
was curious how you guys approached that
yeah we we didn't really so we do you
know expected info gain which are just
like
you do it until you don't really reason
about the value of that information
um and and i mean as you know the
the ideal thing to do would be to really
cast it as a palmdp and then
you would just figure out when to ask
and do not ask the whole one to go with
the thing
um it's impossible to actually compute
that at least so far
so far um and and so in in that
in that sense the the the thing that we
find ourselves doing over and over again
is using looking at the reduction in
entropy
and you know maybe at best having some
notion of how much you prioritize that
versus just
acting uh greedily according to what you
know
already um and and setting that trade
off in some semi-smart ways but
yeah i don't think i have any great
answers compared to what you already
know
on that topic yeah i don't know how to
compute value of information
i think it's a super interesting
question as we think more about humans
and robots collaborating
um uh so maybe trouble i think we're a
little bit over time and i want to be
really respectful of anka taking the
time to join us but um
at least i will utterly thank you again
and i know it's weird to be talking to a
hundred people and not seeing them
um but thank you so much for your time i
think that was a terrific talk and i
know we've
um i think recorded the whole thing and
so we'll be sharing it with people more
broadly
sounds great okay thank you very much
for organizing thanks so much
stay well everybody yeah see you guys
tomorrow